re 4
[拍手]
長年外科医をやっていると患者さんから学ぶことがたくさんあるっていうことに気づく
んです
例えば患者さんが
私は元で非常に苦しいと言ってくれた場合いい
我々は医者としてだけではなくて人としても対処しなければならないんです
多くの患者さんは我々にこんな素晴らしい事言ってくれます
私たちの経験や医療の情報をぜひ他の患者さんにも役立ててくれと
よしわかったでも残念ながら
その人のデータはその人のものでしかなく他の患者さんに価値をしづらいですよね
例えばみなさん自分で撮られた事あるレントゲンや採血のデータ健康診断のデータは誰
かのために活用したことってありますかなかなかないんですそれは個人情報だから他に
配れないのとさらに
維持医療の技術や医者の知識が暗黙値といって
文章やデータで伝えられるよりも体の動きやベテランの知識で伝わるようなそういった
ものが多く暗黙値のまま
伝わらないことが多いんです
最近医療の技術がどんどん進みレントゲン画像は3次元を簡単に作れるようになりまし
た
3 d 画像で臓器と臓器癌や結果非常によくわかるようになったんですが残念ながら
まだ
平面のモニターの中で見るに過ぎないんです
つまり見ている人はそこから動かず本当の奥行きを把握できない
いいんですね皆さんもスマホやタブレットテレビや映画
四角い枠にとらわれてるっていう不自然さに意外と慣れてしまって気づいていないん
です
医療の技術がさらに内視鏡手術という進化を遂げました
お腹を開けるのではなくてカメラを入れて手術をするんですが
傷を小さくする患者さんのメリットに反し
四角い
平面のモニターで限られた視野しか見れず
空間を認識するのがなかなか難しく
技術を向上したり間違って五入することを回避するこういったものを妨げてしまうん
です
そこで
一つ素晴らしいアイデアを思いつきました
臓器と臓器の形や関係だけ
データとして座標に抽出をすれば週2の時に的確に空間が分かるのではないか
コンピューターを使うと患者さんの ct やレントゲンからそこの臓器だけを正確に
抽出することができます
最近は人工知能やディープラーニングを使うと自動で一つ一つの臓器のデータを別々に
抽出することができるようになりました
これをすべて座標のデータでコンピューターで再現をするとこれをポリゴンと言います
ポリはたくさん
ゴンはカードつまり多角形に変形できるんですね
このデータを変更することで
自然な立体視ができるようになりました
バーチャルリアリティを体験できるようなゴーグルを使って右目と左目立体的に表示を
すると被っている人には脳の中でこれが一つに
しかも自分の周りすべてを囲むように体験ができるんです
もはやマウスやキーボードが入らず自分が自然に歩くとデータが後ろにいってくれる
つまりその空間がが自分が没入しているような体験ができるようになりました
もちろんただの cg ではなくて患者さんのデータ一人一人からこれを人工知能や
コンピュータで簡単につ
れるようになったんです
ただ地図を見るだけではなくて患者さんのレントゲンの中に手術の器具や
どこからアクセスをするこういった位置情報を統合することでまさに
カーナビゲーションのような機能を果たすことができました
カーナビが作れるということは自分の位置と相手の位置を他の人にも知らせられると
いうことです
下手らのドクターはどのように切っている分かってはどこが失敗しやすい
こういったことをみんなで共通に kirk することができ
合併症や週2時間を減らしたり
技術の向上を促進したりすることができます
さらに手術の方法を一人一人的確に計画するために患者さんの情報の中にその人に必要
な医療器具を
その元のデザインのデータのまま3次元で表示するそんな機能も開発しました
そうすることで
例えばこの背骨の手術の患者さんはスクリーをどの角度でどの深さでどの位置に入れれ
ば
背骨がまっすぐになるかこういったことを術前に計画しながらその1と一応正確にもう
数ミリ単位で計測をすることが出来ますこれにより
ベテランと若手が
どこが違うかという評価ができたり若い人がどのぐらいで上手くなったかと言う
ラーニングカーブという技術の向上というのが評価できるようになったんです
これを一般の人にも活用しようとある私の友人の大学教授が声をかけてくれました
彼は脳梗塞を患い血管が詰まっていて麻痺もあったんですがなんとかリハビリでいい
カバーをしました
彼が自分の大学の授業で生徒に生きた事業したいと提案してくれました
彼の脳の mri のデータをいた
滝バーチャルリアリティにしました
本人が自分の脳の中に入る体験です
しかもこれは生徒がみんな見ている事業です
これは自分の中脳の中に入り脳の詰まったところを見つけると
一生懸命擦りだしました
この決戦のおかげで
それを見ていた生徒たちはあっ強い血管
頑張ろう
もうチョコレートとかやめようっていうふうに気づくようになるわけですね
こういった本人が語ることっていうのは本当に人に訴えかけるパワーがあると思います
この大学教授非常に進行深くしていただき
もっと多くの人に活用できるように幌レンズという
もっともっと
簡単にそれがフォログラムのように体験できるデバイスを
まで日本で発売する前に我々にかしていただきました
そうしたところそれに賛同したプログラマーが一緒に感謝を起こさないかということで
声をかけていただき
実は起業をすることができたんですねそのニュースは実はこの follow レンズ
を開発している
マイクロソフトの本社まで話がイティ
テッド遠くにも登場しているスピーカーアレックス切符マンと我々もこのころレンズの
医療活用について模索することになりました
実際の外来で患者さんの説明にこの follow レンズを使って空中に患者さんの
レントゲンを3次元にしたものを複数人で共有することで元の位置はどこから切る
この人はどこが普通と違うこういったことを把握するようになりました
もちろん医師だけではなくて看護師や他の義姉さん医療スタッフがみんな共有をしたり
版者さんにも非常にわかりやすい説明ができるようになりましたこの方は子宮がんで
断層と式を3年前に全摘した女性です
3年前のデータからバーチャルリアリティフォログラムを作り
本人がかぶる体験をしてもらいました
3年前の自分に対面した時彼女は素晴らしい事を2つ言いました
私はもう悪いものから解放されているんだというのが分かった
もう一つ
やっぱり私は女性だったんだという風に言ってくれました
この体験をしていたとき彼女は思わず自分の子宮に手を伸ばし触ろうとしたんですね
もちろん触れないんですが脳の中ではおそらくそれに触れる体験につながり3年前の
自分によく頑張ったねと声をかけたんです
もしかしたら我々はすでに大美味しーを発明したのかもしれません
これを多くの子宮癌予備軍と言われる若い女性たちに体験してもらい良い
子宮がんのに早期発見や予防につなげる活動を全国でしているわけです
もちろん日本に限らずこういったデータは日本語英語
他の言語という壁を乗り越えるんですね
そうしたところたまたま私の友人がこれを頭
あっあこれは献身しなきゃいけない認識を変え研修を受けたところたまたま
元一歩手前という組織が四球から出ました
もちろん緊急手術です
妻はのことに時間が間に合いいい
がんになる前にすべて撮りきれ再発の可能性はゼロだという風に
良い結果が現れたわけです彼女はこの手術の上に言いました
もしかしたらこのゴーグルをかぶらなかったら
危機感を感じなければ検診も受けず
元になるの黙って待っていたかもしれません
これを多くの若い人の例えば学校の授業だとか
啓蒙活動にも今普及しているわけです
もちろん私の本業は警戒です手術中に手術の前に会社の子情報を最終確認をし
手術室のテーブルの位置や機械の1人の位置を瞬時にスキャンをしてこの二つの座標を
合わせます
そうすると患者さんの目の前にその人の状況が再現できるんです
ベテランと若手が wi-fi で1を共有することで同じ位置に
把握ができるようになりました手術の前もカンファレンスも直感的になり手術の練習も
ただ模型を縫うのではなくて実際の人の動きに合わせて原田で覚えることができました
あまた臓器の位置にぴったり位置を合わせるとまるでその臓器が透けているような3 d
のプロジェクションマッピングというのも可能になったんです
さらに
どこから切ったらいい床に穴を開ける正確にしなければいけないという情報まで
そこから提示できるようになりましたこれはガイドですねナビゲーションの先にガイド
という概念があります
そこに確実に導いてくれるということです医師はこれを見ながら医療器具を挿入し正確
で安全な手術ができるようになっ
たわけです
これをもちろん
健康な人にも活用したいと思い妊婦さんの心の部屋に使っています
例えば妊娠中本人が自分の中を見ることで赤ちゃんが元気なのがわかれば
うつの予防や愛着障害の予防につながるかもしれません
もちろん旦那さんにも非常に有効なツールでした
2人で一緒に見たいと言っていたので2人で見るようにしていたところ私すごいことに
気づきました
家族写真を撮ったんです
おそらく生まれる前に家族の絆というのを初めて
形にしたのではないでしょうか
この子供は無事に生まれ
より愛着が深くなったと言ってくれました
うちの父は90です細かいことを言ってもわかりませんでも直感的に把握をすれば家族
が病気に向き合い
健康に語り合う時間をコミュニケーションを作れるようになるんではないでしょうか
暗黙知を構造化データにすることで形式知に変えます
個人情報も汎用情報になるため我々社会が医療を担えるようになるそんな第1歩に
つながると思うんですそれが皆さんの過程の中でも既に始まっているんです
ぜひそういった情報に触れる今日はきっかけにしていただければ社会が医療を担う湯の
中が作れると思いますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]